Дніпро — місто-мільйонник.
Зараз це — місто, яке будується.
Але в 1990-х та на початку 2000-х років
тут практично нічого не відбувалося.
На початку минулого століття
наше місто активно забудовувалось:
будувались заводи, і навколо цих заводів
будувались цілі вулиці та райони.
Зараз багато цих заводів уже не працює.
Це дуже перспективні території
для освоювання креативними індустріями.
Починають з'являтися проєкти,
як-от Центр сучасної культури,
коли будинок стояв більше 20 років занедбаним,
і зараз його починають реконструювати.
Центр сучасної культури у Дніпрі —
це культурна міжнародна інституція,
яка поєднує різні культурні організації
і навколо якої вже згуртувалося
декілька громадських організацій,
які займаються культурними заходами.
Я дуже надихнувся прикладом
європейських культурних центрів,
тому що практично всі ці центри —
це були низові ініціативи.
Тоді я зрозумів, що нам потрібно зробити
щось таке ж саме і що це правильний шлях.
А на Донбасі тоді якраз були активні бойові дії.
І ми вирішили, щоб у Дніпрі та в нашому регіоні
не повторився такий же сценарій,
потрібно тут робити такий великий культурний хаб,
який і об'єднав би людей у нашому місті,
і побудував би міст між нашим містом
та всією Європою та світом.
Ми з друзями вирішили, що у нас є вибір:
або поїхати з Дніпра,
або намагатися щось змінити тут.
Ми почали взагалі думати про місто як платформу
для розвитку громадянського суспільства.
Майдан нас мотивував,
і ми зрозуміли,
що Україна має класних людей,
Україна має шанс бути крутою країною,
і ми потрібні тут.
Ідея створення Центру сучасної культури
з'явилася наприкінці 2015 року,
після вже двох фестивалів «Конструкція».
Це фестиваль аудіовізуального мистецтва
та нових медіа в міському просторі,
який наша організація робить з 2014 року.
Задіюємо близько десяти локацій,
і робимо там поп-ап івенти.
І через якісь сучасні формати
ми намагаємося переосмислити ці старі будівлі
чи привернути до них увагу,
щоб там почалось нове життя.
У радянські часи це місто
було закрито у зв'язку з тим,
що тут був завод «Південмаш»,
який виробляв воєнні ракети.
Тут практично не відбувалося культурного обміну.
Зараз Дніпро відкривається,
і я сподіваюсь,
що наше покоління та наступні покоління
вже будуть більш відкритими
до чогось нового, до експериментів.
Одна з головних цілей Центру сучасної культури —
це намагатися давати нові знання молоді,
щоб вони реалізовували
свої ідеї та свої проєкти тут.
Ми хочемо, щоб цей Центр був все ж таки
центром для діалогу, для обміну,
для навчання, для того,
щоб знаходити якісь нові сенси.
На міжнародному рівні ми хочемо,
щоб Дніпро як місто і дніпряни
як діячі креативного сектору
стали помітними у світі та Європі.
І щоб дніпряни й наше місто
стало більш відкритим до всього світу.
Тому резиденти, як-от Альянс Франсез
або Чеський центр, — це дуже класний клей,
який зв'язує наше місто і наших людей
з культурою інших міст й інших країн.
Цього року ми робили великий проєкт
«House of Europe Festival».
Це був дводенний фестиваль,
на якому були презентації кращих кейсів
креативних індустрій з України та ЄС.
Були воркшопи, і також була розважальна програма:
були концерт «Вагоновожатих»
та фільми від української платформи Takflix.
На національному рівні ми хочемо,
щоб ми як дніпряни почали робити
якийсь крутий український продукт,
яким можна буде пишатися всім українцям,
і, звичайно, ми плануємо співпрацювати
з різними українськими організаціями.
Наприклад, вже зараз ми працюємо з «Ізоляцією».
Ми разом з «Ізоляцією» є
членами мережі Trans Europe Halles —
це європейська мережа центрів культури.
Цій будівлі більше ста років.
Це пам'ятка архітектури місцевого значення.
Архітектурна концепція того,
що ми тут робимо,
була (як ми її назвали) концепція невтручання.
Ті приміщення, які мають історичну цінність,
ми вирішили реставрувати.
А все інше, те, що виглядає зараз як лофт,
цегляні стіни, ми залишили як є.
Тут збереглись колони, стелі,
атланти, мармурові сходи.
Також автентичні дерев'яні двері й ці перила.
Зараз поки що етап зняття старої фарби.
Ось, до основи, до гіпсу.
Потім буде укріплення — це другий етап.
Потім доведення елементів, десь сколи,
десь взагалі немає елементу —
треба наново це вибивати з гіпсу.
Це буде головний івент-простір
всього Центру сучасної культури.
Тут будуть відбуватися концерти,
мініконференції, зустрічі,
презентації, відкриття виставок, наприклад.
Під одним дахом сконцентруються
декілька публічних просторів.
Наприклад, тут на першому поверсі буде розташована
галерея сучасного мистецтва «Артсвіт»,
бібліотека, книжковий магазин,
і буде невеличке кафе.
А на другому поверсі будуть вже
виставкові простори всього Центру культури.
Також буде лекторій,
і ще буде молодіжна лабораторія Ksi prostir.
Коли наша команда Kultura Medialna
побачила цю будівлю,
а тут 2 800 метрів квадратних тільки будівля,
потім 1 000 метрів квадратних — двір
і 500 метрів квадратних —
ще гаражі для військової техніки,
які ми плануємо перебудувати
в майстерні та студії.
Ми зрозуміли, що в такій великій будівлі
ми не зможемо робити контент самі,
ми не зможемо наповнити цю будівлю
та оживити її самостійно,
і тому потрібно тут робити такий
креативний кластер і збирати однодумців,
які також змогли би тут
розвиватися і щось робити.
Галерея «Артсвіт» —
це галерея сучасного мистецтва,
яка має колекцію радянського
та сучасного українського мистецтва.
Як будь-яка галерея, ми працюємо
з виставковими проєктами, з постійною програмою.
У нас десь сім-вісім виставок на рік.
Також ми проводили вже два роки резиденції.
Також у нас постійна освітня програма
для дорослих і дітей.
Ми сподіваємось, що станемо
таким простором можливостей
для митців і для наших майбутніх резидентів.
Ksi prostir — це молодіжна лабораторія,
яка займається кросжанровими культурними заходами.
Наприклад, вони і роблять
невеличкі резиденції, виставки,
іноді — концерти,
і займаються неформальною освітою.
Ми створюємо середовище
для молодого українського мистецтва.
Ми дуже натхненні тим,
щоби допомагати молодим митцям,
особливо локальним художникам,
щоб вони могли розвиватись тут.
Для цього ми тут створюємо
відкриту майстерню Maker Space.
Тут можна буде приходити
працювати над своїми артпроєктами.
Взагалі хочемо розвивати художню спільноту,
щоби молодим людям і загалом художникам
не хотілося виїжджати з міста,
щоб знаходити якісь нові можливості для себе
і щоб вони могли тут залишатися, працювати.
Взагалі в мене технічна освіта,
але мій брат був диджеєм на радіо,
і я з дитинства слухав класну, цікаву музику.
А вже потім я сам почав робити концерти,
почав робити фестивалі.
Я навчався один рік в Вишеградській
академії культурного менеджменту.
Після цього я багато їздив на стажування
в Дрезден, Любляну, у Польщі був.
Я завжди хотів повертатися в Україну,
тому що я розумів,
що тут обліг дніпровський,
де можна робити все.
Якщо ти хочеш робити дослідження,
то це ще ніхто не робив.
Якщо ти хочеш робити
галерею сучасного мистецтва,
то у нас в місті всього одна
галерея сучасного мистецтва,
і можна робити ще п'ять.
Я хотів би бачити Дніпро сучасним.
Але потрібно зберігати й
ось такі пам'ятки архітектури,
не консервувати, а вдихати в них
нове життя, нові сенси,
робити щось сучасне в цих будівлях для того,
щоб вони продовжували бути актуальними.
Якщо ми не будемо пам’ятати нашу історію,
то ми не зможемо зрозуміти,
що нам робити далі і як нам себе
ідентифікувати в цьому світі.
Україна для мене — це, по-перше, люди.
Саме вони формують айдентику
та поняття «що таке Україна».
А ще Україна — це дуже класна частина
нашої планети, у якої є все:
море, гори, яри, передгір’я,
рівнини, степи, дуже круті ліси,
тому я не дуже розумію,
що потрібно ще людям,
щоб бути щасливими та
не залишати цю країну, я не розумію їх.
Тут дуже круто,
всім рекомендую приїжджати в Україну!